بعد مرور 11 شهرا على بدء الحرب الروسيه
على اوكرانيا لا تزال موسكو تحاولوا فرض
سيطرتها بالكامل على اقليم دومباس اذ يسعى
الجيش الروسي مسندا بمليشيا فاكدار
والقوات الانفصاليه المواليه له الى تحقيق
تقدم حاسم على جبهات الاقليم الساخنه خلال
الاسابيع المتبقيه من فصل الشتاء في محور
باخمه الاستراتيجي غربيه حيث لا تهدا
المعارك تقول القوات المواليه لروسيا انها
نجحت بالسيطره على بلدتين جديدتين هناك
القوات الاوكرانيه من جانبها تقول انها
خابت ما سمتها معارك حساسه في بلده اوبنه
جنوب شرقيه
واستهدفت قوات روسيه على تلك الجبهات
في حين هزت سلسله انفجارات جراء قصف روسي
عده مدن واقعه تحت سيطره سلطات كياف غربيه
وجنوبا جونيورز ابرزها اكرام تورسك ودروس
كيفك
بموازاه التطورات في اقليم دوم بس افادت
هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه باجتداد القصف
الروسي على المناطق الماهوله بالسكان في
مقاطعه خرسون وزابولوجيا جنوب شرقي البلاد
بحسب الهيئه فان اكثر من 20 بلده في
زبرجها تعرضت لقصف المدفعي خلال ساعات
الماضيه
القصف الروسي استهدف كذلك قرا واقعه على
خط التماس في مقاطعه خرسون
لكن هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه اكدت في
المقابل نجاحها بتكبير القوات الروسيه
خسائر في كلتا المقاطعتين